- I don't like the phrase Fake News
because it delegitimizes the word news.
I don't think there's
such a thing as fake news.
If it's fake, it's not news.
I would use the only in quotation marks.
I prefer to call it Imposter News
when it literally takes the
masked head of a newspaper,
the front of a newspaper,
the layout of a newspaper
and tries to pretend it is the newspaper
as it traffics misinformation.
So that kind of identify theft,
I'm happy calling it Imposter News.
But most of what people,
who are legitimate inquirers
about it, are talking about,
is what I would call viral
deception, VD, venereal disease.
(laughs)
It transmits quickly.
You would like to
quarantine it if you see it.
You certainly don't want to catch it.
If you catch it, you don't
wanna give it to anybody.
You'd like to eliminate it.
[Woman] I think we use this.
- Viral deception has no source
that is clearly identified,
or it's an imposter source.
It traffic in misinformation
and importantly,
when it is caught and
corrected, it does not correct.
One of the hallmarks of journalism
is when it makes a mistake, it corrects.
And the stuff the traffics
through the viral deception,
VD channels, moves among
like-minded communities
who are disposed to believe
it, as a result, are uncritical
and are not exposed to
the counter information.
Or if they are, less likely to accept it
and that is.